bienvenidos a reportero es el magazine
de los grandes reportajes de la
redacción de france 24 soy herminia
fernández comenzamos
hoy les traemos un reportaje sobre la
guerra en ucrania desde el donbass con
un acceso excepcional la batalla por el
donbass la región oriental de ucrania se
ha convertido en una guerra de desgaste
los rusos celebran los pequeños avances
mientras las tropas ucranianas están
ahora a la defensiva en la región cuando
link de bono siguió la vida cotidiana de
los soldados ucranianos en el campo de
batalla se dirigió a la posición cero
nombre dado por los ucranianos a la
primera trinchera frente a los rusos día
tras días los militares ucranianos
intentan frenar el avance de sus
adversarios
francotiradores artilleros y soldados de
infantería luchan por cada metro de
terreno y pagan un alto precio por la
guerra aquí la historia
[Música]
en el frente de este soldado y lucha
contra sus compatriotas
cambalache es el seudónimo de este ruso
comandante de una unidad ucraniana de
paracaidistas
tax karma
desde mi punto de vista el kremlin es un
mal sin nivel sal todo el mundo debe
luchar contra él
este es el campo hace dos días estaba
limpio y ahora quemaron una parte están
buscando no tienen suficientes
referencias aquí todavía así que están
buscando a nuestras posiciones están
tratando de llegar a nosotros las
tiendas este comandante era opositor de
vladimir putin en rusia en 2015 se robó
a los combatientes ucranianos
veo a este régimen como un tumor que
hace metástasis en el cuerpo de nuestro
planeta
si nos exigen los conflictos que hay en
la tierra
siempre puede encontrar la mano del
kremlin detrás pues atrapados en rusia
luche contra el régimen de putin tanto
como pude
participe en acciones extrañas difunde
información sobre los crímenes del
régimen de putin hablo
pero ese mapuche natal es caro
y entonces comprendí que la primera
línea de la lucha contra el crema estaba
en ucrania así que me fui en gracia
queremos la joya y se volcara
su unidad cava incansablemente bajo el
ruido permanente de la artillería en
esta guerra de posiciones para
sobrevivir hay que ir bajo tierra las
rotaciones en la trinchera frente a las
tropas rusas duran tres días los
soldados lo llaman la posición cero
es muy difícil mentalmente
si realmente una gran prueba
[Aplausos]
no se pregunta si estará a la altura de
la situación a la que se enfrenta
ya sean bombardeos o llevar a un herido
o un muerto o cuando te disparan
la primera vez pensé que no había
acabado lo suficiente que tenía que
acabar más aún más para proteger la
cabeza para poder meter los hombros
pensaba dios mío he vivido tampoco no he
visto nada de la vida luego se me pasó
me tranquilice no había pánico nada de
eso
ah
primera herido grave del día para la 25ª
brigada aerotransportada
ah
y los médicos deben estabilizar a este
soldado lo antes posible
su jefe de sección está a su lado
sucedió algo alrededor de las 10 de la
mañana los compañeros dicen que el
enemigo disparó primero un mortero de
120 luego hicieron ajustes y un tanque
empezó a disparar desde una posición
camuflada el proyectil alcanzó sus
piernas y recibió fragmentos en la parte
inferior de las piernas
[Música]
por qué
y
estamos bajo fuego desde medianoche no
21 horas
llevamos cuatro días así el fuego
enemigo dura 21 horas al día
el enemigo quiere asaltar nuestras
posiciones
y pasar a la ofensiva del monstruo
los heridos leves vuelven al combate
inmediatamente otros afectados por la
explosión de un proyectil están en
condiciones de volver al frente
pero tal vez no es eso
[Música]
en el donbass los bosques suelen
proteger las trincheras que quedan casi
indetectables entre la vegetación
y prize dos francotiradores vigilan
y
recibimos información de que en esta
zona había un grupo de saboteadores
se nos ordenó avanzar hacia esta zona de
bosque y vigilar
una misión rutinaria para ambos otras
son más arriesgadas como el día en que
fueron enviados tras las líneas enemigas
cerca de la ciudad de donets controlada
por los rusos
hace un mes tuvimos que entrar en un
pueblo temporalmente ocupado
entramos por la noche allá estuvimos
caminando durante dos días entre los
rusos
cuando las tropas rusas pasaban por ese
pueblo
les dispara vamos desde un lugar y luego
nos trasladábamos a otro habíamos
llevado suficiente munición
se hartaron porque sus compañeros morían
y no entendían de donde el pueblo era
suyo pero sus compañeros morían igual
me gustó el hecho de verlos en pánico el
primer día
ese día matamos a tres de ellos los
vimos llevarse camas autos estaban
saqueando el pueblo mientras saqueaban
matamos a tres tipos rápidamente
respondieron con artillería hacían todo
lo posible para atacarnos sin
importarles dónde estaban sus hombres
entonces entraron unos estúpidos
francotiradores y dispararon con rifles
anticuados indiscriminadamente hacia
todas las ventanas lo vimos todo nos
fuimos nos hizo reír
en medio de la noche con todas las luces
apagadas
una sección de la 95ª brigada
aerotransportada se prepara para
desplazarse a la posición cero
la primera trinchera frente a los rusos
un soldado prepara las granadas se
utilizarán si las tropas rusas asaltan
la trinchera
oksana francotiradora de la unidad y
bojan el comandante están concentrados
preparando la rotación
yo soy el que elabora las listas de los
que son enviados allá por lo que tengo
la responsabilidad directa sobre cada
uno de ellos y
ahora rusia está poniendo todos sus
recursos disponibles en la batalla
en serio luchamos por cada metro por
cada metro
también hay que entender que en la
lógica de rusia no pueden retirarse sin
una victoria mínima
excepto que el pueblo ucraniano no
acepta la bendición
así que es ahora en el sentido más
literal de la palabra nuestra guerra
patriótica ucraniana por lo que durará
mucho tiempo
es
oksana y bojan dirigen la sección hacia
el frente estos hombres tendrán que
mantener su posición bajo el fuego
durante 72 horas es una tarea agotadora
pero aquí nadie quiere oír hablar de una
tregua y mucho menos de negociaciones
si algunos en europa piensan que hay que
ceder territorio ucraniano
les sugiero que empiecen por darle a
rusia parte de su territorio
así como muestra de su buena voluntad
que quede claro no cedemos nuestros
territorios
si alguien piensa eso o es un completo
idiota o un agente bajo influencia rusa
de madrugada los soldados relevados
durante la noche y regresan de la
posición cero el cansancio no parece
afectar su ánimo en cuanto se guardan
las armas la unidad de informaban el
comandante
también siendo 22 30
los tanques avanzaron hacia nosotros en
parcelas
pasaron a ambos lados del terreno para
desplegar su infantería
uno de los tanques comenzó a disparar
una mina explotó todos sus planes
terminaron
qué habría pasado si los rusos hubieran
avanzadas
estábamos acabados habrían invadido el
área así de simple así también matamos a
uno de sus exploradores lo matamos a
quemarropa ese explorador estaba
arrastrándose por ese maldito campo los
chicos estaban cavando las trincheras él
parece uno de nuestros chicos le
preguntan que nieves no de dónde eres el
tipo dice soy de rusia entonces los
muchachos le disparan deberían haberle
hecho un interrogatorio sucio y haberle
disparado después no era más inteligente
hacerlo así
stanislaw y oksana son pareja
se conocieron en la plaza de la
independencia en 2014 en quien se
manifestaban por una ucrania libre y
cercana a europa
y la cosa personas
atravesamos juntos la plaza sana fue
herida en la plaza y yo también
luego cuando empezó la guerra en 2014 me
ofrecí como voluntario para luchar y
desde entonces pasamos por esto juntos
cuando este gran ataque de rusia se
acercó tomamos la decisión de permanecer
juntos
es un gran honor luchar en la guerra por
una nación tan hermosa como ucrania y
estoy orgullosa de que ahora la gente
pueda vivir en paz en kiev bajo un cielo
tranquilo gracias a los que están aquí
en el frente
es una locura recuerdo tanto 2014 la
emoción cuando yanúkovich se escapó
habíamos ganado si vamos a ser europeos
no más corrupción
no más policías torturadores y bueno
aquí estamos todo empeorado
[Música]
hace ocho años jaroslav también
participó en una manifestación en la
plaza de la independencia
hoy es oficial de artillería
ese día él y stefan su compañero se
acercan a las líneas enemigas para
colocar sus grapas potencia cohetes
múltiples
[Música]
nos desplazamos a una nueva posición hay
que entender dónde está el enemigo en
relación con nosotros dónde están los
objetivos de interesantes su armamento
tenemos que entender muchas cosas para
poder atacarlos así que vamos allá para
conseguir esa información para entender
varias columnas de humo se elevan
alrededor de esta carretera la zona
subjetivo de los rusos antes de recibir
la orden de disparar jaroslaw y sus
piezas de artillería nunca se quedan en
el mismo lugar la orden de disparar se
da nueve horas después los grados se
colocan en un claro una posición
calculada por jaroslaw el día anterior
es un duelo de artillería que se juega
aquí en el campo del donbass
[Aplausos]
es rutina pero estoy un poco nervioso no
cambia de posición siempre hay algo
nuevo
y la posición puede ser nutritiva
cuadrado actitud gástrico
ah
[Música]
jaroslav tiene que corregir la precisión
mientras se oye la artillería contraria
el objetivo es alcanzado otras tres
salvas de cohetes luego los grados
abandona en la zona en cuestión de
segundos para evitar las represalias
rusas jaroslaw y su unidad se
trasladarán a una posición en otro lugar
del frente estas maniobras sólo sirven
para un propósito para el comandante
les podría banksy un poeta resumió la
idea nacional de ucrania
déjennos en paz y su can ya no son el
pueblo que pone la libertad por encima
de todos si los ucranianos queremos
vivir en malas condiciones
es nuestro derecho si queremos entrar en
la unión europea tenemos derecho a
elegir ese camino
eso es la libertad
darnos la posibilidad de elegir lo que
queramos por eso luchamos
para todos los que están en el frente de
la cuestión es sobre todo ganar la
independencia de su país de una vez por
todas
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]